welcome everybody um
i have received apologies from
councillor london councillor carey
councillor hawhi and councillor white
um
i'm not aware of any other apologies
unless you've received any alex
and those are all the ones i've received
okay
um we move on to item two declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest in any of the items on the
agenda this evening
okay
i'm not aware of any questions from the
public um
unless alex you've received anything
uh no questions have been received thank
you
i believe counselor dylan has a hand up
though
oh
sorry counselor dylan
oh perhaps that
jane you're on mute
i know that counselor dylan is
struggling um she's having to access the
meeting via her
phone which will probably be
oh he's out
sorry denise yeah i'm just saying i may
need to declare an interest because
preparation for adulthood is on and i've
got a child in that system and also for
the offset i have got uh i'm enough um
sorry
i've had a busy day i am a
governor
for and i'm responsible for looked after
children at a school um
so i just thought i'm maybe should
mention that as well thank you that's me
okay
thank you
um
we've received the minutes of the
previous meeting are there any comments
or concerns about those minutes
no we're happy to accept those then
thank you
and we move on to our first report which
is a preparation for adulthood um
we have had the papers um so if you
could just give us a quick overview um
the headlines of that um
report
thank you
thank you thank you councillor weston um
um
it's it's really great tonight actually
that we've got representatives
from across education health and social
care so uh there'll be a number of us um
sort of reporting in and and taking
questions etc um which hopefully you'll
find helpful is it worth councillor
westerners all introducing ourselves
just before we we move on
yes please if you would that's great yep
no problem so uh karen samples director
of education for trafford um if i bring
in colin
if you know i'm colin reynolds interim
service manager for the learning
disability team adults
thanks colin
sally
hi sally smith i'm also interim lead for
inclusion
thank you sally and finally jackie
that's not normally how jackie sounds i
have to say
are you there jackie
jackie may be struggling there so um
we'll we'll we'll progress anyway thank
you um
are you able to share the slides alex
because i thought we'd just put a
slideshow on just to walk us through the
report if that's okay
and obviously we can make sure that this
slideshow is shared with you as well
after the meeting
oh that's lovely so if you want to move
us on
alex on to the next slide that would be
great thank you
i thought first of all um i'd just share
with you um a um a data dashboard
actually that we've recently established
in trafford um particularly for um our
children and young people with special
educational needs and it's proving to be
a really helpful mechanism i think for
us to to store uh performance data
um and and also it's been used to report
into our send strategic partnership
board on a number of factors and it's
really helping us to to understand the
system better
enables a much greater understanding of
what our performance indicators are like
and on this particular table here this
has been taken from our dashboard
it hopefully shows the the number of i
suppose that the level of special
educational need rates we have by our
school year group so this is probably up
to december 21 so there will be some
changes um but this is the last kind of
reported data that we were sharing it's
quite helpful actually because we can
see the volume of young people coming
through the system where some of the
pressures may be
but also how we compare with some of our
greater manchester counterparts
including stockport which is one of our
statistical neighbors
and i think what you can see there in
that bottom bar chart is how our numbers
do kind of grow particularly when our
children are going through year four
year five year six they're getting ready
to transition into the secondary sector
and then we see that drop off from year
eleven at eight percent uh to year
twelve at one point six percent and so
on through to year thirteen and year
fourteen now that's particularly school
year group and but it's quite an
interesting um set of data just just to
share with you
what we can also see we can also draw
data on gender
ethnicity so again we really get an
understanding of the profile of the
young people moving through the system
thanks alex
the next slide then shows some
performance outcomes for our children
and young people in trafford and again
this is something our k our key
performance indicators that that were
really important to us when we when we
monitor the performance of our children
and young people with special
educational needs
now there is always again a lag in the
data so there tends to be a more of a
delay just because of the reporting
outcomes this has actually come from the
local government association it's a
benchmarking tool that we use again to
support us with performance indicators
and some of the complexities that kobe
brought
around outcomes and sharing of outcomes
data is meant that we don't necessarily
have
some of our educational data uh of 2021
just because of we it wasn't necessarily
reported in it wasn't a statutory
requirement for schools to report it in
but you can see there at the top our key
stage four so that's us really our 16 to
17 year olds with special educational
needs support in education employment
and training is above national at 91
and i've actually got the data for 2021
and we held it at 91 so that stayed the
same so we do very well there where we
do need to improve is our keys our 16 to
17 year olds with an education health
and care plan who are in education
employment and training because we are
there below national 87
and actually our 2021 data dropped again
to 82
so that is something that we are having
to keep an eye on and it does fall into
one of our ambitions in the action plan
around performance indicators and
entertainment outcomes
but overall our cohort do very well
compared to national in terms of those
who do stay in education employment and
training and you can also then see that
the performance indicators for our 19
year olds with special educational needs
achieving a level two and a level three
remain well above national we do
exceptionally well there and our key
stage five so that's kind of your
um
i suppose your your um year 12 year 13
um cohort
again those that are in education
employment and training are well above
national at 88 so so that number stays
very very strong
thanks alex
i just wanted to remind you of our our
greed ambitions really our priorities
for special educational needs you may
recall that this these came from a
visioning day that was held with parents
and carers and obviously professionals
as well from across education health and
social care and these were the the
things that were tested out during our
recent send peer review
and i think what's really important to
remember is that these are owned by all
partners so the professional leads for
these ambitions are from across the
local area uh education health and
social care and they're responsible for
really overseeing the progress that we
make
and that fourth ambition that kind of is
in bold there absolutely is aimed at
looking at making sure that we are in
fully integrated that we work together
that we coordinate across the local area
to make sure that our children and
families experience a really positive
and seamless transition not only from
transitioning into adulthood but also
early years into school
primary into secondary all the different
points of transition that a child and a
young person may experience
now we know things aren't um perfect we
know we've still got a way to go we know
we still have to improve that transition
um but it is owned we we've absolutely
identified it as an area for priority
and it is something that we're really
working hard as a partnership to address
i think the most important thing there
is that the voice of the child is is the
golden thread really that needs to run
through all of these ambitions and we're
working hard to really try and raise
that raise the profile of our children
and young people and make sure that
they're involved in you know the roll
out of those ambitions
thanks alex
this one we we've shared i think before
our joint strategic needs assessment
which is really helping us to understand
how well we know our send population
and you can see there really that you
know we identified that preparing for
adulthood outcomes could be improved you
know and the joint strategic needs
assessment identified that that was
largely because the attainment data
wasn't as strong we've actually improved
that now which is really really good but
but we also know again you know we have
to recognize there's been a drop in
those young people um with a plan who
were in education employment and
training in that the experience isn't as
as positive for all of our families and
young people as we'd like it to be so
we're trying to show there that the jsna
has identified it and again we're making
sure it links into our priorities and
our ambitions as we seek to improve
thank you alex
now i don't know whether jackie's there
and whether she can help with sharing
this slide if not i can talk through
this slide
are you able to to talk now jackie
i don't think she's there so i'll i'll
carry on if that's all right councillor
weston
what i've tried to show there are those
four um outcomes that are linked to
preparing for adulthood so you can see
you know it's it's all aimed around
making sure that
we really um explore the different
employment and education options that
are are open for our young people
that we we want to ensure that we
encourage that that drive to independent
living that young people have that
choice and control and freedom over
their lives and the support that they
have
that we're really beginning to think
about
how they want to be participating in
society having friends having those
relationships and most importantly as
well having good health so these
preparing for adult outcomes are central
to our planning but also they're
contained within an education health and
care plan
so jackie says she's definitely here but
she just can't speak at this stage
unfortunately it might be jackie that
you might want to put things in the chat
if any questions arise
jackie coulton is actually our chair of
our um transition board who who oversees
the uh preparing for adulthood
and jackie and noah is really keen to
make sure that that board drives forward
a really clear policy and strategy
we do have a pfa protocol at the moment
which you'll be aware of what we don't
have yet and what we need to get to is a
public facing
um
that's kind of well understood strategy
that our our parents and our families
are really engaging and understand so we
need to really translate it into
something that is owned and understood
by our children families
and and their parents
thanks alex
i know sally is going to talk through
the next slide which is how pfa is built
into our ehc plans thanks sally
thank you karen
hi so this is just explaining what our
duties are really within our send code
of practice around ehc plans and pfa
um we have to
build in um
planning around pfa from year nine
that's the statutory time um
however in trafford we're trying to look
much earlier the code of practice does
expect us and want us to look at it from
the earliest stage
and you'll have seen from the report
we've shared information with schools
and others about planning and having
those kind of discussions from from you
know within primary and we've also made
um alterations to the way our plans are
written through our ehc plans in
trafford and now have the the pfa four
outcomes that karen's just
uh discussed um from year six so when
we're planning for year six transitions
that's when we start to look formally at
the pfa outcomes and that's how they're
written into ehc plans as they move into
secondary and that was a change
um over the last year
um so but from year nine there has to be
that formal um focus and discussion
and getting the right people around the
table
and for those meetings is a key area i
think for us to carry on developing
we've we've looked at um
supporting schools particularly by
making sure the annual review paperwork
is also focused around those areas so as
they're reviewing the outcomes that
we're personally sorry that we're pfa
focused from primary into secondary you
know that we're um we're really making
that a person-centred review as that
second one says
looking at making sure people have got
the right training to put the child at
the center listen to all views but also
then try and get make sure the right
agencies are there certainly from year
nine so we've got health and social care
where they're needed to be um involved
and
you know what schools are usually good
at is getting
the careers advice
um appropriately there but again we
realize that that sometimes the quality
of that isn't you know people aren't
always as knowledgeable and we need to
make sure that the people are
knowledgeable in in the options for
young people with send as they move
through
and because the careers advice some
schools buy into connections some
schools provide their own independent
careers advice so it's making sure that
that's um equitable and knowledge you
know those people are knowledgeable
we've got some very skilled staff but we
need to make sure that offers um
consistent i think transition planning
again that has to be built in so we've
taken the focus with annual reviews with
school um particularly to make sure that
their
we changed the paperwork a couple of
years ago to make sure that the
focus is about celebrating the year's
progress
um for usual annual reviews but then at
key points of transition there is a
focus on rewriting those outcomes for
the next key stage and that that very
much focus on transition again we know
we've got a way to go with making you
know improving that um but we're
certainly on that road
and
um the plan there as it says that the
other two points are really about health
and social care
making sure that we're coordinating that
integration of health services um
for the young person and uh
that they've got the the access to an
adult care transition assessment if
needed so i don't know whether there
might be questions around that for colin
later on or for jackie but again health
and social care being that key so it's
not just an education review when we're
planning for the next steps thank you
thanks alex
colin i think you were going to talk
through this slide
yeah thanks karen and and thanks
everyone for allowing me to attend
tonight so
this this is the trafford pathways that
we've developed over the last um six to
nine months really
um and just to sort of echo what karen
and sally have spoken about and jackie
is about that collaboration
so when we talk about pathways it's
about establishing
a a
sort of singular pathway that is suited
and most appropriate for the young
people
that are moving through
the the pathway for adulthood
how they are is we sort of got pathway
one which is independence pathway
as the slide says young people with the
acp is unlikely to need care and support
into adulthood
second neighborhood so that's about our
engagement with colleagues i come from
the complex needs service so it's about
engaging with our colleagues in what we
call localities
and that's our neighborhood social
workers and other professionals
and then the complex needs pathway which
i'm more involved with
are those young people with more complex
needs
that will need
more stakeholders in terms of the social
care the health and when we talk about
health
it's collaboration with jackie but also
our community physios occupational
therapies helping people to meet those
four outcomes
and that's that's how we're going to to
navigate the journey and make sure
everybody has access to the support they
need
to live that better life
thank you very much thank you thanks
alex
as i say we did have pfa as part of our
peer review and we deliberate
deliberately chose that area to be
looked at because we knew it was a
priority for us and the feedback that we
received as you can see the positives
were certainly they recognized that we
are seeing emerging improvements they
still need a way to go and they still
need to be embedded but we were going in
the right direction
what was lovely we that the young people
that they spoke to said that they were
confident about their transition which
was lovely to hear and and certainly the
group of students that spoke felt that
they'd had good support from their
schools and colleges which is lovely but
but also from our sensory impairment
services and that was that was really
recognized
i think it was clear from the reports
and from the plans and the reviews that
our educational psychology service and
again our sencos were using the pfa
outcomes as a basis for their reports um
and and there was a real commitment from
everybody to learn from practice and
really be responsive uh to the young
people's changing needs so the worst you
know lots of positives thanks alex
however they did give us some
recommendations as well and and i was
going to talk through the first two and
sally hopefully talk through the the
latter two of these bullet points it was
clear that what we need to do better is
to use that jsna that joint strategic
needs assessment to make sure that we're
really responding well to the changing
and emerging needs
of our children and young people as they
do move through the system and really
make sure that you know we can provide
our children within that opportunity to
live and learn and grow close to home
and and be local
i think the second point as well was
really important was we have a
designated clinical officer the dco
and we're looking to hopefully recruit
very soon our designated social care
officer
and and i think once we have those two
people really embedded in post there's a
real fantastic opportunity for them to
to ensure that they've got that
strategic oversight of transition so
that they can really hold our children
on our young people and our families to
help that transition to be really
seamless and make sure that all the
right support
is wrapped around them so i think they
saw that as a perfect opportunity to
harness to improve this area
sally do you want to just talk through
the latter two please
yeah
excuse me um
i think the communication is key isn't
it and i think we've again we we know
that's an area for development um partly
some of that will be through the local
offer and information that we get out
there to families and that's been
developed at the moment there's um i
think there's a link in karen's report
to
one of the pages i'm preparing for
adulthood but there are foot there is
further information under the send pages
but again once it's okay just putting it
on the website we need to make sure that
everybody understands that and that
that's communicated as clearly as
possible and that we're listening to
families about their experiences
building that in as karen said through
the jsna to to then you know keep
changing that offer
and i think it's about the services as
well so we there's a training module
that gets mentioned i think later on
that we've we've developed
prior to just prior to covered really
but i think things have been put on hold
a little bit and that's about training
professionals um in all areas to
understand those key transition points
and what needs to be filled in what
needs to be discussed with families and
when and the information that needs to
be shared so again that's we're picking
that up again now
and that's one of our next steps and one
of the gaps which we're very aware of
it's um certainly not just a traffic
thing but it is you know it is very
important the employability pathways i
think we've got some real successes and
and
not saying every you know it works
brilliantly all the time for everybody
but certainly at the most severe and
complex um
area i think with young people we've got
some good pathways for transition um
however into adulthood this is however
with some of our more able young people
perhaps leaving mainstream trying to go
to fe college those transitions are not
always as successful as we'd like them
to be and they have been particularly
hit i would say through the pandemic so
we're looking at those now
we're at the early stages of that but
we're certainly taking that very
seriously looking at those we've got
some as some of you know we've got some
options there for young people with
autism
um
rather than some of the traditional
supported internships
which have been aimed at those with more
of a learning need but um we've we've
got gaps we're looking at them we've got
some providers we're at the start really
but we certainly need a better range of
providers and more flexibility to be
more and bespoke for some of those young
people or and try and make sure that
things and you know that they don't make
a transition that then fails before then
we look at something else and that we
get those transitions right from the
start
thank you thanks sally
thanks alex um this really was just to
say that you know the this is the part
of the action plan actually that covers
ambition for and as i say that's
actually held by jackie coulton and emma
brown as well who um you know is a
director for adult social care um and
and clearly is driving the work of the
the transition board to so we're
absolutely making sure that you know
we've got really clear performance and
quality assurance reports that we're
tracking and monitoring constantly that
as sally said which we're identifying
the gaps and really understanding where
the current processes need to need to be
improved and making sure that that
training package as well is rolled out
so so it's identified there within our
ambition plan
thanks alex
i've kind of wanted to end on on a bit
of a positive really and talk about two
of our kickstart trainees um we've
actually had two fabulous apprentices
that have actually made a significant
contribution um to actually developing
content for our young people on the send
local offer and using some social media
channels
and over the next six months they're
going to be promoting and developing
that local offer they're actively
engaging with young people specifically
as well as families and trying to make
the content
really fun and accessible so there'll be
lots of videos about send sessions and
young people can really see what's
available available in the borough and
it was actually through that mechanism
that we had one young person
with special educational needs who was
really struggling to access a provision
at gorshill and it was through using a
video that actually encouraged and
incentivized them to attend so it's a
beautiful success story that was
actually developed by our kickstart
trainees
and actually you know we do have um
one of one of our trainees does have
special educational needs themselves and
i think they're really making a valuable
contribution just making sure that the
send youth perspective is really
understood and heard particularly by the
local area so it's just been beautiful
to hear their voice and see their
contributions in our work
thanks alex so finally it's just our
next steps really which i think you've
seen in the report i think one of the
most important bits there is our parent
experience panels we know that you know
we need to understand the lift
experience from our families and and
both both positive as well as some of
the times when it's been challenging and
so a no traffic parent carer forum
through the communication engagement
group are setting up a series of parent
experience panels which hopefully will
will really support and drive forward
the improvements that we are seeking to
make
and that's it thank you very much
councillor weston
thank you everyone for that very
comprehensive report um
can i make a personal request could we
have a copy of the slides
it just it's just easier to um read and
look at than um the paperwork but that
would be really helpful thank you do any
members have questions at all
council of maitland
you're on the mutsu
and i'm sorry i i can't find my hand
anywhere i do apologize i'm not i'm not
used to zoom i'm used to teams but uh i
can't find it um you might have answered
some of these questions uh throughout
there but i find it difficult trying to
take information and think about what i
want to say as well um in in the report
that was sent through um
liquid logic was um mentioned and one of
my questions was is our parents and
young people able to access liquid logic
yeah
i'm
very used to talking about the liquid
logic system across with senkos and
others um
the the at the moment not to see their
ehc plans um and but that is that's one
of the ways we use it liquidlogic's the
whole broad system and we have um
sections of it for social care
adult social care children social care
and then we have an early health module
which is where the ac part sits so it's
used it's one of those systems that's as
good as the people that use it you know
so the more services that use it the
better the information and where
social care and
education use it a lot health have got
access for providing advice for um ehc
plans
um and we use it for our panels etc so
we get a lot of we're getting better
data from it all the time so we're
building information in there that can
be seen by social care education and
health at times around the pfa um
system you know process i suppose which
is why it's mentioned in the report
there are though other and jill might
want to come in because there are is
that your hand yeah i was going to say
there are there is work on a portal um
which is going to be helpful for us for
kind of outer borough schools and other
things like that but i think there's an
element there that could be open for
parents and things are progressing with
social care aren't they jill so i'll
stop talking and let you come in
so thanks for that sally and um great
question but essentially liquid logic is
the electronic database for our services
and so if you think about gp records and
how they hold them electronically within
the system it it that's the way that all
of our records come together
but as sally's saying it's really
important that we think about how we
make that accessible
how we share information but even more
critically how people um whether it's
our students themselves or whether it's
our parents
fully um
are engaged in the process of the
information gathering and what is
inputted into the system because words
mean different things to different
people
and um
one of one of our trusted colleagues
used the beautiful phrase of our record
should be about creating
memories and stories
for our children and young people and i
think that's a real acid test isn't it
about have we written something in an
accessible way is it helpful to people
in terms of planning and taking things
forward
and
and if we opened up the system to
everybody it would be like opening up
the all of all of the gp records but
actually critical information shouldn't
just be shared we should be agreeing
what that information is and how that's
going to be used so i hope that helps
answer your questions so
so that you someone mentioned a portal
then so
so within the electronic system there's
different workspaces there's different
bits one of the applications is
a portal application so as you can
upload information and you can download
information from it
so
it's not just what people put into the
system the system has different
capabilities and we have to look at how
we can maximize that capability to make
it inclusive
okay
thank you
i've got i've got a few questions i
don't know whether
to fire them out or
yeah should i just should i just go
ahead yeah and
when i was looking through the report um
that was sent through
um i i clicked on to i think it was in
the employment section and and
look where there's ideas and
opportunities for young people and i
came across the voluntary volunteering
opportunities
and um i thought well i'll click on that
see what that has to say and um
the first one that i came across was the
cyril flint opportunities for young
people to go and volunteer with that
group
and the information that was on there
was wrong
and so i suppose my question is is whose
responsibility is it to update that
traffic directory for young people
yeah we do in terms of the local offer
and the directory we do have a dedicated
local offer advisor i think don't we
sally and certainly one specific for
send um so it it
there is an officer that's dedicated to
it what we need to make sure is that um
as well people all agencies feed into
that because that person won't know it's
wrong unless somebody tells them that
it's wrong and that you know so it it
does need to be a bit more of a
collaborative offer i think
the records on the directory are
generally managed for the family
information service aren't they karen
and they do try and
agree who is responsible for each record
you know whether it's the a provider
that needs to update them and alert them
if there is an update or whether it's um
a school or you know so there's lots of
records on there there should be
somebody who is responsible and then the
family information service have that
overview and can update things if needed
i'm only mentioning it because it could
maybe put someone off you know if they
try to email someone and then they find
it's blocked because uh and they know
this really helps person yeah
so um maybe i can let cyril flint know
them myself get in touch with them and
let them know
um
one of my other questions was
realistically how smooth is this
transition
from
the the school
uh and um coverage uh going into
adulthood with them the therapy services
ending and going into therapy needs met
by gp
how smooth does is that realistically
colin do you want to take this one
sure yeah so i think it's variable i'm
not going to say anything and this is
where the
the sort of pathways are discussed is
about that earlier
alerting to people and their future
needs and
i think within the the complex pathway
because we're a collaborative team with
the cheshire world partnership that they
have a transition coordinator we need to
replicate the people not in the complex
pathway in the sort of neighbourhood and
another pathway how we replicate that
so i think it is variable and definitely
an area that we're looking at improving
i i if i could if i could come in
councillor maitland and one of the
things that i think will be incredibly
helpful to us in terms of your question
about is it smooth are those parents
experience panels that karen talked
about because it's one thing describing
the process isn't it and saying these
are the mechanisms these are the
processes that we follow but the
experience of that and
how helpful that is to a child or a
family is really really important isn't
it and you can't
you can't write that down it is
listening to people their experiences
and working with them to to improve it
so
it's one of the things that we're super
excited about we think that we will hear
some challenging things we know we will
hear some challenging things but
actually the first step of really
getting to grips with things is
understanding that experience standing
in somebody's shoe so it's absolutely
the right approach it's absolutely the
right thing to do
because i know what i think might be a
good idea probably isn't what will work
for a young person yeah you know they
probably see me as a boring gold adult
that knows nothing about these things so
it's really important that we do
bring that lived experience right
into the center of everything that we
can do which is i know some of the
thrust of your questions in terms of how
smooth is it how accessible is it
it's absolutely right that we work with
people
that are experiencing these changes
and recognizing the impact on the adults
as well as all young people
um you know so
like i say i'm really excited about
what that will further add to the work
and we will incorporate it into the
ambitions plan to be able to respond to
it
so if
if um a family aren't happy with what's
happening the process where where which
direction do they go
to
you know is it is it the monitoring
group is it the
the board the um preparing for adulthood
board
sally probably wants to come in here
i was just going to say it depends i
suppose on the setting they're in at
that at that point in time uh councillor
i would think if they're in a school it
would be the senko they would be
alerting
and if they're in that transition it
might be their ehc coordinator
because they're there to be able to
contact you know health social care
education colleagues if necessary and
bring things together if it's around the
plan um
there will always be an ehc coordinator
i suppose for everybody with a plan so
they are a really key role and can pass
those messages on to to the right to the
right people because those groups like
the monitoring that should feed into
them but the monitoring is that kind of
internal internal process group
but yeah whoever's the parent can tell
whoever they think is the right person
if you like so the senko the ehc
coordinator i would say with the two key
people
they may also counsellor go to sendias
as well which is obviously the
independent advisory service as well um
who who can really kind of support and
advocate on their behalf as well so so
there are lots of mechanisms by which
people can raise any concerns
and and the sorry i'm just going to say
the trafford parent forum do hold
regular face-to-face discussions you
know with parents where they can raise
issues and also our ehc team manager
teresa has um a phone line for
on a weekly basis that the parent forum
can pass parents over to to ring and
discuss any issues so uh yeah quite a
few routes there thank you
can i just throw one last one in now the
um the board which i believe is
established now
and is it operating
yeah yeah is it sorry i couldn't get off
mute this uh councillor yeah yes it is
it is operating and as i say you know
we've got very strong membership now
across that board which
and again is is that's going to be a
mechanism to hear those lived
experiences as well as well as drive
forward those improvements
uh well i suppose what i was thinking
was how many cases so far have they
dealt with do you have that information
we've not dealt with any specific cases
as such um because as i say you know the
cases will have been dealt with
indirectly or through the hc
coordinators as sally has expressed
we're at a point of developing those
parent experience panels and again
bringing case studies to to the the
board so we've not commenced them as yet
but it's certainly that's in the
pipeline for you know for next steps
okay i'll i'll stop now i'll let
somebody else come in sorry
does anybody else counselor acton
thanks chair
um just briefly really i wanted to say
you know i'm pleased to see the
performance indicated uh because it's
really helpful to be able to compare
against the
national averages and
you know that does help in uh
when we're delivering the services
uh
and and similar with the
pfa plans
um
you know
it's really good to see those plans in
the way that they're set out but
all of this is
dependent on delivery
and i think that you know
that has to be
constant monitoring of that delivery
um and i'm really pleased to see you
know the parental panels i think they
are critical um
uh you know to be able to listen to
parents and there will be challenges
but that's what we want we want
challenges because we want to know
what's actually happening uh to to to to
their young
uh you know uh
charges really so um
that that that's very positive and and
clearly listening to the young
young people themselves is absolutely
critical i know that's been said and uh
but it's something we have to do but
it's just comments really yeah thank you
counselor and i completely agree with
you i mean that was the whole reason we
we requested the peer review and the
whole reason we specifically asked for
pfa as well to be to be a key line of
inquiry because we didn't shy away from
the the areas that we knew we had to
improve i think what we really need to
to to have validated that that we were
going in the right direction and
actually those ambitions were the right
ones and the actions were the right ones
i completely agree that traction is
really important and obviously the send
strategic partnership board which um
uh councillor carter sits on as well you
know that is the mechanism fundamentally
to to kind of have oversight of the
progress of the ambitions plan but that
also reports to the startwell board so
there is some you know strong governance
arrangements that sit around that we're
actually um doing a deep dive on pfa for
the next sun strategic board which i
think again is the deep dives are a
really effective way of getting views
from all stakeholders and again making
sure that we've got clear sharp
measurable uh activity then that
progresses from that
agreed
thank you um councillor bennett did you
have a question
thank you counselor western my hand
seems very vanished and i was just
interested in the three pathways that
you've mentioned
and it what wasn't clear was how much
input young people have in the decision
which pathway they will be directed to
so if you can clarify that
yeah so thanks for that if i if i pick
that up that that will be part so the
pathway will be part and parcel with the
golden thread of the young person's
voice and would be very much sort of
active work
as we we saw to talk about until it
touched upon year six to nine
and the reviews and the contact and that
increased sort of scoping work whether
say scoping that involves talking to
young people
going to see them wherever they are and
feel most comfortable and forming
opinions and identifying pathways
what i i loved i went to the the
strategic development day and there was
a mum
who was at that and said
if you spoke to her son's lunchtime
operator that would be the person that
would would give you an insight so i
think it's about creatively thinking
isn't it
of obviously parents carers sisters
brothers but also looking
at people that you might not necessarily
identify and doing that work earlier on
developing that to make sure that our
pathway is right for that person
and we're meeting those outcomes so
it's a collaborative process and to
answer your question
the young person will be very involved
in the the identification of that
pathway
but again it's lived experience isn't it
because that really stuck with me from
that day
about looking at who's in the person's
life sees them every day those really
well beyond the family and can have that
that depth so it it
really stuck with me that day
thank you colin um counselor dylan did
you have a question
thank you um i've just got a couple of
short ones if
can i just ask how who the parents on
the
parents experience panels are and how
they
how you find in those and
just help i just want it more of an
observation really for me personally
i've found loads and loads of barriers
of a young person that is over 16
and i think there is lot there are lots
of things that we could probably do
health wise for instance just one
example is the covid vaccine i know that
there were some care clinics in
manchester because my young person is
needle phobic but i'm batted from
different place to different places they
keep sending me back again
for some sort of assistance with that so
basically there hasn't been any my next
question would be
it mentions in one of the reports ep
reports may be undertaken for an update
can i ask how many were done in the last
year or the last cohort that you've been
doing
transitioning um just i've written down
adult care transition assessment i
wonder if we could just have a little
just an update what does that actually
mean and the pathways um one the
independence the neighborhood and the
complex needs i'm struggling to kind of
visualize that i think for the complex
needs what i can but for the first one i
wonder if you could maybe talk us
through
what that might look for a young person
i'm struggling to get my head around
pathways and how does it look what is it
a virtual thing is that a real thing
thank you
thank you councillor dylan um i mean
that there could be um
one of those questions that we might
have to take away when you ask for how
many of the ep assessments because
obviously we'll have to do a little bit
of um you know checking of the data but
we can certainly come back to you with a
response i mean certainly the parent
experience panels um as i said to you
that that's that task if you like that
piece of work is being undertaken by the
communication and engagement group and
trafford parent carer forum our key
representatives on the communication
engagement group justine bailey actually
is the lead professional for that first
ambition so she's obviously going to be
critical in in you know identifying and
and sourcing families that are going to
be willing i think as well uh to to be
able to share those experiences but but
we also recognize that uh trafford
parent care reform can't possibly
accommodate all families and all parents
as well and we do we are through the cne
group working hard to make sure we kind
of extend
uh that that that kind of reach uh as
best we can but but they're going to be
charged with that if that helps with
that response and we can certainly keep
you in the loop with with that piece of
work
and as i say the ep assessments bit
we'll probably have to go back and get
some data around that sally i would
imagine
um i know jackie's put in about the
needle in the chat i don't know whether
you can see it on your phone counselor
dylan but jackie coulton has actually
said that the gp practice nurse is able
to support with needle phobia um but i
think you know certainly in terms of the
pathways i don't know whether sally and
colin want to to share a little bit more
information around um what it may feel
like for a young person who is up you
know certainly the independence
and the neighborhood pathways
karen if i can chair if i can just come
in i have put in the chat whether it
might be helpful for us to provide some
case studies in terms of the different
pathways
because the
the opportunity to bring it to life i
think would really help people you know
my ambition is to ban the word pathway
don't you karen and just to exemplify
you know these are the sets of
circumstances this might be how we
consider those needs and this would be
how that decision making was made so i
think if we look to work up some
anonymized examples that might really
help because
i totally get where counselor dylan's
coming from reading something in black
and white and saying if it looks like
this you go through this this and this
sometimes can be confusing hence my
ambition to to ban the word pathway
because what is the pathway it's
something that stands out outside my
drive
and i know that's been overly simplistic
but it i think if there were any things
like that that would be helpful to bring
things to life
for the committee then that's something
we could look to do
thanks jill i think that would be really
helpful um
if um if there are no more questions can
we move on to item six which is youth
provision in trafford um we have had a
copy of the slides in advance um
conscious of time so um
i don't know if andy's going to uh
present this one but if you could just
talk us through give us a brief overview
thank you
yes of course thank you um
do you want me to work off my slides or
is somebody going to pop pop them up or
what would you prefer
alex are you able to help or
i can do it i'll just take a moment for
me to get the slides up in just one
second
thank you
councillor weston and uh uh hello
everybody very nice to meet you i'm uh
really pleased to be talking to you
about this service i think it's a great
service that we've uh we've developed
over the last couple of years so it's uh
it's really nice that i'm getting the
opportunity to update you on that now
and obviously if you've got any
questions as we go through um i'm more
than happy to answer them
um and if there's anything i can't
answer i'll obviously come back to you
uh so in terms of the
uh the service
i'm just waiting for the
slides again a lot like one of the other
councils i'm used to teams rather than
zoom so it uh it throws you a bit when
you're
using a different system ah thank you
very much
next slide please
okay so uh first thing to point out on
the slider and this part the reason i
didn't want to show you slides was um uh
what you're looking at there is a p is
the side on picture of our new um
uh mobile unit so if we it's not a
minibus as such it's actually a uh it
just takes three members of staff but
there's a it's a large vehicle there's
room in there to work with young people
um and it's really important for a
detached youth work team to have a
mobile unit so that's our brand new unit
we haven't received the keys yet but
we're only a few weeks off um and that
was funded by
um mostly funded by hotel football um i
think their supporters pay a pay a levy
or used to pay a levy uh to come into
the building on match day and and uh
very kindly donated that money to us so
um that's a big chunk of that um and we
are hoping to launch that so there'll be
some press marketing around that
in the next few weeks so uh so watch
this space um apologies the picture's
not that brilliant but that that was
just um
the factory where they're refitting the
the vehicle uh that we took a snapshot
of
um in terms of the vision um it's about
empowering young people to achieve a
better tomorrow
we are working with going to work with
young people over the summer on the
vision and mission statements um because
they they need an update as to the
objectives
um if you just pop along to the next
slide for me
oh i think
uh
there was one missing wasn't there page
oh sorry piggy bomb
nope
that's right yeah so in terms of
detached youth work um that's a
definition this is um
a definition
for street based youth work
uh which is provision that operates
without use of a center and takes place
where young people are at both
geographically and developmentally
now that doesn't mean
that we don't use centers but we're not
based there so we've got
all the staff work out of
our talk shop base
but all our delivery for the street talk
team is out and about communities um so
what we do is in the winter months when
uh young people aren't out on the
streets as much and it's the weather's
poor we do hire venues partner venues
and we often deliver jointly with
partners out and about in communities
but those venues will change so we're
not
we're not
um
we don't stick to one center and we
really go where young people need us to
be
it is a universal service
but we do target areas of need
and what you find for instance in
partington um
as an area of higher need um actually um
there's very high demand for young
people in that particular area for
instance if we go out on the streets we
know we're going to be busy there so um
so it does make sense and it does work
um
so the full-time workers that work on
the street talk team also carry a small
caseload and that's really useful so
when we're doing um issue both youth
work out about in the community um
that's
where we deal with young people who need
more of a
uh an early help offer then we can
actually work with them over a period of
weeks and see them either in school or
out in the community or at our talk shop
base
to do a bit of one-to-one work with
their specific issue and they don't have
to do that out and about on the streets
where that's not always
the right way to deliver that work
so young people have a range of needs uh
right away from universal and also i
think it's important to say that we also
work with young people out and about
who who
who need intensive support um we know uh
many of the young people that we work
with that we we engage in on the streets
have got some social care involvement uh
some of whom go missing from home some
of whom might be at risk of exploitation
so it works really well because we work
as a service that we feed in um to other
services uh where those young people
might be at risk and we talk to gmp
community safety etc so so i really want
you to
to see that it's a joined up service and
that when we're out and about the
streets we you know we will recognize
young people that are getting um that
need intensive support and we link in
with other services when when we come
across them
um majority delivery um march to october
is out about in the parks um mostly it's
in the parks sometimes on the streets
and we tend to go where young people
congregate so um you'll see later down
that
we do a lot of work in the west and um
there are some parks in in the west
especially by the river mersey where a
lot of young people congregate from from
across trafford so again we target those
areas if you could pop onto the next
slide
so these were the original aims and
objectives that were set in 2019
uh to 22. so so it's
it's strange to think really but we only
set up the team actually in 2019
um when we took over from the youth
trust and
um these were the original aims of the
service i'm not going to go through them
because you can see them and obviously
you've got you've got access to the
slides um what what i want to do in the
summer again
is is to um now we can do it um is to
get to get a a a conference with with
young people where we check that those
aims and objectives are right
um and also look at our our vision and
mission for the service going forward so
um so that's sort of taken us to the
point we're at now um and kovit hasn't
particularly helped in terms of the
development service um
but i would like to say that we we're
looking to develop those further next
year over the next year
if you can go to the next slide
thank you very much um
so this is just the history of potted
history and again i won't go into too
many details
there um
um but in our fir so we launched
officially in november 2019
uh and we ran for for five months and
then we went straight into lockdown um
obviously nobody was expecting that and
that did really change the nature of the
work that we were able to do
in that first year
um
so
in in the development stage the service
delivered a hundred youth work sessions
five nights a week and we had over a
thousand engagement young people
um a lot of that was um
uh about
developing the universal office so at
that point the service was going out
talking to young people about what do
they want delivering in their areas and
us us and our staff finding out you know
where are the places to go to meet young
people and what were the sort of issues
that we were
developing and then unfortunately we
went straight into
to lock down so we didn't really develop
the work like i would have liked to that
that that original first summer
um
and what we concentrated on then uh
there was a period when our staff
weren't allowed to be on the streets
um but then as soon as we could
certainly back in june 2020 we were back
out and about but we mostly had to
concentrate on public health messaging
and large groups weren't allowed to
congregate so
it was more mental health support
responding to community safety in asb um
and community referrals so so it was it
was light touch
um
and across the borough so we did the
team went
um very much across the borough uh and
then from march 2021
uh today we really refocused our
activity um because it's it's not very
good to develop um
uh informal education opportunities for
young people
if we're never in the same place at the
same time and we're chasing
young people around the borough to
deliver public health or
on community safety it's better to
develop
a piece of work in in specific areas and
i'll go on to tell you a little bit
about what we've been doing there and
what that means is the numbers the
massive numbers don't necessarily
increase
um because we might be working with
groups of 10 15 20 young people in an
area but we might then be working with
them over a period of um
eight to ten weeks doing a specific
piece of focused work
and the importance of doing that is that
that is work where you can measure
outcomes on those young people
and you can evaluate the impact that
it's had on them and we also talk to
parents about
the differences made so
so that's why we've moved to that and i
won't apologize in in many ways for
reducing the the the mass number that we
were
we were we were visiting first and
focusing it down on on those individual
pieces of um
evaluation work and once we finished
doing a piece of evaluation then we'll
go to another area and work with a
larger group and then off the back of
that do that universal work and then off
the back of that do some more focus work
again so it's an ever evolving picture
if you could uh scroll up the next slide
um so that's um some headline figures
for localities this is just this year uh
quarter one to quarter three so by the
end of this year we'll we'll be looking
at two thousand engagements for young
people
you can see it's heavily weighted
towards the north and the west and
that's partly because of where some of
the projects have been this year uh for
instance seymour park uh the the skate
park the west area uh where we get large
numbers of young people in in various
parks
south and central's less but i would
point out uh we we had some
figures missing unfortunately we had
staff off with kovid
um
and
um then we had some other issues but
just because we aren't out there doesn't
mean that partners aren't delivering uh
we have recently delivered uh start to
deliver some stuff on the broom wood
estate at blue skies premises
um and that's working really well that's
a friday night session that we're
delivering there um um but in sale west
for instance um although we're not out
on the street that at the moment in sale
west uh you've got gauce hill detached
youth work team and foundation 92
so what we try and do although you won't
see them in africa
there are engagements going on in those
areas um
and we coordinate with partners so we
don't all turn up at the same place at
the same time
um so you can see again uh we're
concentrating on the areas of higher
need
um
but we're also talking to young people
across the whole of trafford um
one of our area areas i think i want to
develop
uh some work in his sale more for
instance uh in the coming year um and
also um we've
we would like to develop some work
around um ultra interchange and the
leisure center where we know young
people congregate so we haven't
forgotten about other areas of the the
borough we are developing that work and
we will move around from the areas that
we're in if you could pop onto the next
slide
um for every session that we have we
have a debrief at the end of the evening
and we collect details of the issues
that young people have raised
um and we report on these through our
monthly performance reports
and our quarterly reports that go to the
yes steering group um
so
um it won't necessarily be a surprise
especially because with we've been doing
this through the period of covid is is
that emotional well-being and mental
health are two of the highest factors
that we've been dealing with that young
people have been raising with us
um education school
has come second so that's issues young
people
maybe need to offload about their
experience of school i think school's
been very very disrupted
for young people um and
you know the opportunity for them to
talk to youth workers out and about out
of that school setting has been very
useful and our staff as you'll see from
the case study i'm about to to talk to
you about
our staff will work with those schools
and communicate with schools if we pick
up issues that we need to then go back
to school so so certainly if we pick up
those bullying issues or we think there
might be an incident between young
people then we'll we'll talk to the
pastoral leads in those schools so
again it's not work done in isolation
when we're out in the streets at night
and that's that's something we follow up
with the schools the next day
uh positive activities was third
um and then relationships and sexual
health um
was fourth um there's about 20 factors
that we measure but i just wanted to put
those there because those the ones that
young people would were telling us that
that were most important to them
um and then we had an example for erbs
and we had a talking news project in
ermeston uh which is a great title to
engage with young people
and it's about um
online sharing uh of
you know photographs naked um
for young people were sharing
inappropriate photos of each other and
the peer pressure that young people felt
to do that and also
um it opened up that conversation around
consent and we know that um some of the
sexualized sexually harmful behavior
that young people have been displaying
in schools again not helped by lockdown
um and the the sharing that you see not
helped by lockdown
um
uh uh
is an issue for for young people and
schools and communities so that's
something we we took out into emerson
when it was something that was
identified by young people and partners
that that was an issue that needed
addressing
if you could pop onto the next slide
so this is just a
picture of what we've been doing this
year
um and like i say so i'm not going to go
through them in great detail but what
i'd like to point out is that when we're
doing these projects they're led by what
young people are saying they need
um in those communities
but they're also led by what our
partners are telling us and what might
be going on so for instance in um in
seymour park we're working with tough
sea on skate park projects and improving
the provision there for young people um
we've just recently started um
delivering to young carers in
in the center of sale they've been doing
some group activities with grip
adventure and now what we're doing is we
we're sending a couple of staff along to
their sessions and we're doing the issue
based school uh youth work with them and
then obviously if we we get any issues
that we can we can refer back into into
appropriate services off that so that's
just a flavor of the stuff that we're
doing um if you pop down to the next
slide
thank you
um
so this is a case study so um i think
it's really useful to to see the
linkages so we had a referral um
uh one of the young people that we met
out in skate park in
um you know trafford seymour park um
one referral was made into talk shop
from this session so we've got a weekly
allocations meeting that the youth
engagement service run where we allocate
uh young people that are referred into
the service
and that was referred back into one of
the
street talk youth workers who took it on
as a case work
they were on a reduced timetable at
school had some mental health issues um
and also self-harming um
and the youth worker
worked with them really well to to
improve their confidence and self-esteem
uh and the young person was supported in
meetings with the school so that that
work would go into school uh and provide
a bit of advocacy and support um and
they were back onto a full-time
timetable and you know the proofs in the
pudding you guys have helped me so much
i feel great about myself you know
that's why our workers do the job that
we do
um
and and the team also we have feedback
from the team so it was you know just a
pleasure to see the way that she
developed um and then she was helping
other young people out in the skate park
so it isn't just about that young person
then they can become peer peer role
models for other young people out and
about
if you could move on to the next slide
so um
i'm not going to read this word for word
because you've seen it in the report but
again um some great feedback that we
receive from young people but i think
just as important is the feedback that
we get from parents
um and i particularly like the first one
um
where
the parent talked about her daughter not
being being quite shy
and
not wanting to participate in social
activities
and this was an art project that we did
with the hideaway in
partington
um and uh
you know the daughters become more
socially engaged positive attitude
change
in her uh great support network for the
community and she was saying for years
they've been asking for this support um
uh and it was it was great to to hear
that they were being listened to and i
hope it continues and indefinitely we
have got plans to continue working in
partington so hopefully that that parent
will see that and and other parents in
the area
so if you could pop on to the next slide
for me
um
so in terms of the partnerships that we
offer so we work very closely with the
community collective
um
and the various youth groups so we work
with gauss hill tough see
grip
we're going to be working closely um
with the boys and girls club of of gm
and screaming wheels who are based over
in partisan so party to new centers
you'll be aware is being redeveloped
um and we've got plans in place to work
do some partnership work with them when
that that reopens as well um so this is
really just a list of the
the different parties that we're working
with at the moment
but um it's it's it's not it's not
limited so as we develop the work over
the next
uh the coming to two years then you know
i would hope that we'd work with with
other other partners
and there may be
pop you know part of our work is to help
the community to develop the offer in
their areas through volunteers and
others
so it might be that new new youth groups
spring up um um and part of our remit
will be to support them um
either as joint deliverers or um or to
help you know in terms of the expertise
that we have in in delivering those uh
those youth work solutions in area
if you could just pop down to the next
slide
um so i was also asked just to give a
little bit feedback on uh serious youth
violence
and i know um
you know this is this is a really
serious issue that we're facing in
trafford
um
and one that
concerns us all and upsets
uh young people parents carers and and
all the staff that are working with them
that we've uh we've had two young lives
and
recently that we've lost to knife crime
in in the borough um
uh what i would say is that there's also
some great work going on so we have been
funded through the serious youth
violence fund
to increase the sessional activity and
youth work across trafford so as well as
the street talk team
um being funded to deliver some
additional work and all our staff are
trained
um in delivering knife crime
interventions with young people so they
can have those conversations
um about the reasons why
you shouldn't be carrying a knife and
the risks of doing so
but also other partners foundation 92
and early break um are also um
out there commissioned to deliver those
sorts of activities
um
uh
and then there's also the the mentoring
which has been really effective
so behind the headlines
i'm really pleased to say there is some
great work going on
um and uh our youth justice colleagues
i managed the youtube team until
recently so i was involved um in in the
men setting up the mentoring program um
just uh in the first year of
functioning uh we worked with 40 young
people that excluded 11 perm exclusions
and that's really important because
young people we know who are exclusive
from school are much more likely to
become involved in criminal activity and
we also know that the majority of those
the mentors work with
remained in education and then didn't go
on to commit uh violent or serious
offences so we know that that works um
what i would say is that um
uh the lesson that we've learned from
street talk and
uh the mentoring work is that you need
to start early so we need to be engaging
with year 12 and 13 young people once
that
knife carrying behaviors becomes
entrenched at
16 17 years old is very very hard to to
to change
can i just move on to the next slide
please
uh so gaps provision issues
and staffing is a is a is an absolute
headache for us um um partly with the
victims of our own success here um so
i've lost uh
three sessional youth workers in a
full-timer in the last six weeks um
um but they've all gone on to to
full-time jobs so the work that they've
done in on street talk and the the
skills they've developed
um have um have have got have have given
them
the opportunity to apply for full-time
permanent employment but that that has
left a hole so so we are constantly
recruiting youth workers um and there's
a there's a big issue out there uh
across gm across north west is that
after 10 years of austerity there aren't
the trained youth workers out there um
and there was no um apprenticeship
routes now the apprenticeship groups are
coming online and there's a there's a
new degree apprenticeship starting in
september but uh um which we're looking
uh to see if we can support any new
apprentices on on that route um so we're
working quite closely and the other
thing is that we're working closely with
partners because there's no point us
um recruiting and ignoring our vcs
partners what i want to do is
is work with vcs partners to recruit the
workforce across trafford so that we all
have um new
uh adults coming into the to the youth
work world um
and we're looking to to put on joint
training
um and other opportunities and we're
gonna promise that anyone that wants to
come in uh that they get the opportunity
to volunteer with us um that we mentor
and support those uh those new staff
that we potentially offer them
uh guaranteed interviews so so we're
looking at a range of things and we're
also talking to our local colleges about
what training can be put on
uh the pandemic as you'd be well aware
has had a massive impact on the service
and that that has
really held up our development by about
a year i think
in terms of the type of work that we're
doing but we really are doing that
project work now as well as doing the
universal office so i think um that's
that's coming on but we need to get to
together with groups of young people uh
to develop our
aims for the service to develop over the
next two years
um the localities work um
uh we haven't covered all the localities
and i already mentioned sale more and
more town centre will be priorities here
for the
2022-23 um yeah you could just pop onto
the last slide
you'd be glad to know i'm i'm
nearly done
uh
so um
these are just the objectives so we've
got the new mobile unit i've already
mentioned
uh youth work training i've already
mentioned the mapping uh i think we need
to work with young people and partners
across the piece to talk about to check
if there are any gaps that we're not
aware of um so i think that's a task
that that i i want the team to do
and so that we can report back uh by the
by may 22 uh 2022 and that will help
develop our work over the summer
i talked about sale more and launching
them and i've also mentioned the
visioning day and then the last slide is
um just some of our successes
um
so
this sort of links in to a certain
extent with your previous
your previous presentation
um
in terms of preparation for adulthood um
because the engagement service um i put
in two bids for
uh
the esf programs 15 to 18 and and 18 to
24
and we've been successful with 300 000
pounds worth of um funding to work with
230 young people and in particular i
want to work with care leavers and send
young people so that's either young
people who send support
and
and um
and also uh young people who've got
ehcps now ecp is not a criteria for
um
getting an offer but as long as they hit
any other criteria uh and one of those
is being affected by the coveted
pandemic which i think applies to every
young person uh who's been in education
in the last two years then they can
still go on it so that's that's what
we're looking to do is to target our
resources at those particular groups of
young people and we have had some
success already with 16 17 year olds
so uh we've been working with coverage
recovery funding and it's the same staff
i'm using to deliver this
and we had 10
young people who send needs and seven of
those have moved into positive
opportunities including a number into
traineeship so i'm really pleased with
that so i i think that links in a little
bit with with what we were talking
before
uh we've just i've in fact i just
received the email tonight officially
but i already knew because our assessor
had
given us the feedback that we've passed
our matrix accreditation uh which is for
which is the national accreditation for
information advice and guidance uh
providers what i'm really pleased
this year which was different to last
year uh is that that also applies to
street talks so so
uh he went out and spoke to to young
people who were receiving the street
talk service so
so our um it's quite unusual i think for
detached youth where it seems to have
that accreditation but i think it's
really powerful that we've got it
and then lastly we've got the new youth
work mobile which will just make it so
much easier for us to to get about the
the borough and go to those places um at
the drop of a hat where we need to be
um so i wanted to leave on a positive
note um i hope that's been useful for
you
and i will be very happy to take any
questions i apologize i haven't looked
at the chat but if i've got any
questions i'll be happy to answer them
now
thank you andy um
i cut oh i can't actually see hands so
if you'd like to ask a question could
you pop it in the chat please or wave at
me i can see everybody but i can't see
your hands right oh i'm inundated now
so
um
adele's had a hand up for ages denise
right
sorry adele i didn't see that either
adele do you want to start yeah um i
just wondered if it would be at all
possible for
for us to have some focused information
on the um engagement that you've done in
our walls and i asked um particularly
because i live in passington and and i
speak to a lot of young people in
parsington i hear from a lot of them
and
forgive me if i missed it but county
lines is something that comes up quite a
lot here and county lines is something
that the police also you know discuss
quite a bit and if this is something
that i'm really noticing as well um as
um you know i'm an avid litter picker
and i'm finding knives kitchen knives um
[Music]
um
what they called
stanley knives um on the park in the
open where children are playing um and
if we could just have some education
around knife i must be um
being responsible with the fact that you
know you're bringing a knife out with
you and that you're leaving it in a
place where anyone can find it i'm aware
that um
weapons are hidden you know i've come
across a fair few of them but um so that
was just that one
that's sort of one question and then
just to say as well that i think it's
it's really good that you know
encouraging people into youth work and
and i just wanted if there was any kind
of qualification that people could aim
for so that if you just got a casual
interest it might want you to do a
little bit more you know
to have something at the end of it not
even too long of course to have to
commit to
so thank you
thank you very much for the question yes
um so in answer to yes when we do the
monthly monitoring we have much more
detailed information about what
specifically we've done in those areas
um
probably the best way to do that is is
um
i'm not sure what the
the form is i might i might defer to
jill on on that but certainly i'd be
happy to supply the information that's
in that report on what's going on in
that area back to to councils for their
area uh i'd be more than happy to do
that on an individual basis
um
the the second point about knife crime
and county lines and certainly
um
uh when we're out about we work with
young people who we know are uh being
exploited and some of those have been
exploited through county lines um and
the youth workers because we because we
link him with youth justice and social
care and
our complex safeguarding colleagues um
we we do pick that up um so
um so those are conversations that we
would definitely be having with young
people um um
although that does of it's often led by
the young people
um or community safety so if community
safety identified there was a particular
issue in that area um i'm interested in
the number of knives and we have we
actually did some litter picking with
one of our uh members of staff in
parkington uh last year but certainly
it'd be useful to know which park it was
so that i can direct staff
a road park oak road yeah
around the
uk and around the
young children's play area as well
um because i think that would be a a
really good opportunity to send the team
out
and do some work and we can we can we
can look for knives and have those
conversations to young people that are
out there
so
it's generally on a friday evening that
the young people are over there it's on
both occasions it's been a saturday
morning and i go out with picking really
early so fortunately i found it but it
could have been a small child you know
yeah yeah no i think um i think that's
really useful intelligence and this is
the sort of thing we get from community
safety that we follow up um um i need i
need to get generate some more staffing
to be to be fair but
um that is one of my issues at the
moment but um but certainly we'll we'll
look into that and i'll um
i'll follow that up and the team will
we'll go out and do some working parties
and a round out road
um yeah no problem um
you also asked about the training and um
just just to say um this is what we're
discussing with trafford college um so
i've got a meeting actually um in in the
next week which have a college i'm
looking at
the training routes and what the offer
could be to the local population and how
we could develop that
brilliant thank you i know of some
people that are really interested but
they're not necessarily academic and
that's cutting them off but they want
that qualification because they want to
further it and go into it deeper
you don't need to be academic to be a
good youth worker so yeah that's fine
thanks andy and thanks um adele for the
question
um
oh sorry denise um thank you just in
response to your question about
exploitation and counseling you um two
things that i'd really want to make um
the committee aware of we have newly
created or what we're calling a
vulnerable adolescent service that
brings together the youth justice
service our missing
service and our specialist complex
safeguarding team together recognizing
that
for some of our young people they will
have involvement in all of those parts
of the system
and it seems really sensible to
bring the services together to have them
under
lead
and in relation to county lines and some
of the exploitation issues what andy
didn't say in his presentation is that a
number of his staff
have been trained in a particular
relational approach of intensive working
in the exploitation space so it links to
our
what we call our shine team
and um our act model achieving achieving
change together that is all about that
intensity of building up the
relationships having those difficult
conversations working at a young
person's place because quite often our
young people that are involved in county
lines or exploitation won't necessarily
self-identify as being in that
vulnerable position
and it is adults behavior that's causing
the harm to our young people so it's
really important that we engage persist
and stick with our young people and we
do have our violence reduction
coordinator going into schools including
primary schools because andy's point
about getting in early and having the
conversations and i think the words you
use where education
it is really important so we've got that
and we do have um some very structured
programmes and support going in
to schools for our young people thank
you
thanks jill uh councillor maitland did
you have a question
i'm not on my time i know um
andy brilliant it sounds like you're
doing fabulous work with your team um
and it wouldn't your bus looks brilliant
as well i'd love one in every area and
the team and you know enough workers to
go with it that'd be great
um
nitrous oxide canisters um are the
biggest my biggest worry at the moment
as well as knives actually
um
your workers are they doing anything
about you know educating these uh young
people about the dangers of nitrous
oxide
yeah definitely so that they're all um
uh we do i guess there's two two aspects
to that so all the staff the working
youth service have have have some
training in
drug and alcohol advice and education
and that's um and we often will do
targeted pieces of work around that
including some of the community safety
work that we do um so we will talk to
them i mean there's the littering aspect
to that as well in terms of the
the the the the horrible mess it creates
for for the environment and uh uh and
you know residents obviously
don't want to see that at the end of end
of every day but yes so certainly we
would have that education aspect um the
other thing that that we're doing is we
work with early break early break to um
also deliver street based youth work an
early break are the young p the service
commission to do young people's
substance misuse so um so we've got a
very quick referral route into them
because we do some joint uh youth work
so if we know there's a specific area to
target
not only can we if we go out to that
area with the early break team not only
can we give them guide guidance they can
also then tap straight into that service
because we know we can refer into early
break but if you meet somebody out on
the street
and talk to them about
a referral and they'll they might go oh
yeah yeah but you know they're never
going to turn up
but if they actually meet the worker
they might then later engage with from
early break or they say i'm from the
same organization actually
we're really okay we're not going to
force you not to do what you do we just
talk to you about the risks and you know
um
um that works much better so so i think
that sort of joint approach works really
well so um and again
um it's the feedback that we get from
community safety as to where to target
so again it's about uh councillors or uh
and the public feeding back and the
police feeding back where where we need
to be
um we can't be everywhere at once which
are aware so yeah so so so you know and
it might be that you you identify an
area but we can't go there straight away
but we then
uh we plan a piece of work that we will
then do in in four six weeks time
i would be interested in the any
statistics or um that you have for david
hume west as well um while you're doing
adele's
stuff for partington please
yeah we certainly have done a lot of
work out in davey hume park so yeah yeah
thank you thanks sandy and thanks sue
for the question it is something these
uh nitrous oxide canisters i think it's
borough wide um i live in the south of
the borough and it's everywhere it's
every park every bus shelter you just
see them um everywhere um
councillor bennett did you have a
question
you're on mute joe
thanks
struggling with the system tonight
andy
i was disappointed but not at all
surprised that sale more is at the back
of the queue in the 18 years i've
represented this award we're always the
back of the queue
and it's really really sad because
people don't appreciate just how much
deprivation there is in sale more
my ward
consists of a third of social housing
and it's the biggest social tht
social housing unit in the whole of
trafford and it ever we haven't got a
building we haven't got a park we've got
really poor transport in sale more and
we always seem to get overlooked so i
would look forward to telling you what
your plans are going forward andy
thank you
thank you very much uh councillor
bennett yeah uh
i'll take that on the chin because i we
haven't done a lot of work there uh up
to now i i i i'm long in the tooth i've
been around trafford for a while so i've
worked with jamie rennie and people like
that who worked on these days i do i am
aware of uh uh historically and also
they're never actually being uh the
youth service there was the base in
southwest but never one in in salem all
so i absolutely take it on the chin that
we need to go out and do some more and i
i did put it obviously in the slides but
that's not it's not helping you at the
minute but
you know that that will be a priority
for for us to develop work uh in the
future um i'm not
i think i'm a little bit missing in
terms of the community links and who to
link in with the community at the moment
i think that would be really helpful so
if there's anyone that uh
i'm not cherking responsibility here but
if there's anyone that you would
recommend that we talk to in the area to
get things get started get the ball
rolling and understand where where we
need to be then that would really help
me as well so um so if you can do that
um that would be great but i'm uh i
certainly is absolutely a priority for
for the coming year
thank you
thank you andy i'm uh pleased to see
you're going to be doing some work
around altering him town centre as well
um i commute i use the tram on a daily
basis and um particularly in the evening
it has become a bit of an issue i think
um around around the station in
particular
um but thank you for that oh sorry uh
cass did you have a question
i just wanted to make a comment if i can
so it was just on um
on on some of the concerns i think that
members have have raised around knife
crime and nitrous oxide canisters and um
and county lines and i think these are
things that um
every borough really
across the the country are experiencing
um probably in an acceleration in um and
i kind of just wanted to say that i'm
really glad actually that we've got the
youth services
in trafford and notwithstanding and what
counselor bennett has said about sale
more and i think it's a really important
point um but we did bring in our youth
services back in house um two or three
years ago and i think that was a really
timely thing to do actually um and all
of the
um steps that andy is as outlandered are
really strong steps that um will help us
as a borrower to um to tackle those
really really difficult things that i
think a lot of um councils will be
experiencing so it's just to really say
thank you and to to andy and the team
and and i think the work around street
talk and the actually the going out
being proactive in the community um will
be a really great help so linking andy
in with councillor bennett i think will
be um excellent but notwithstanding that
i think it's there's some really good
work that'll help us to address those
difficult issues thanks
kath um
so
there are no more questions can we move
on to um the ofsted improvement denise i
think councillor blackburn's got a hand
up and i just wanted to come back in as
well
sorry
can i just apologize for coming in late
i had a bump in my car early so that's
why i'm like i'm okay well sorry that's
to say i'm late and
my question all my comments was about
the nitrous oxide
canisters um
often in the car parks
um
some of some of the traffic car parks um
people bringing them in by cars
some of them are using themselves for
car drivers but it's attracting the
youngsters obviously to to to to the
dealers as such
um
do we have any feedback
from amy stroke ron trafford about the
the amounts if certain um certain parks
or car parks are being used more you
know for this
um and
you know obviously you know the the the
police looking at it from from a sort of
a police point of view they're they're
going to know where we where the hot
spots are but is is is is this being is
this intelligence being passed on
to to us so that our you know our youth
people um are sort of really up to date
with you know where you know where where
the main
um sites are thank you
so if i can come in um councillor
blackburn two quick things one of the
things that we do do is we do do mapping
in terms of um hotspots or issues across
the borough with our police colleagues
and some of our teams are actually
co-located with the police
and i guess what i would really want to
convey the the reason for looking at
some of the mapping sharing of
information is so as we can continue to
be proactive because one of the things
is that we know that
um actual incidents of harm including
knife crime traumatic as they are
they're
they're high risk high incidents but
that they are low in numbers and i think
some of the things that you've heard
described tonight in terms of the
building of relationships the proactive
approaches the going into schools
is part of that but yes we do
have um
we have regular meetings with the police
we have a number of panels that are set
up and we do do specific mapping
i don't think we get detailed
information from amy but we do get
information about um actual crimes or
incidents um and in incidence of
violence is something that does get
reported across all of gm
and we have um like i say low low
numbers but it's something that we we
want to continue to be proactive around
thanks jill and thanks um linda for the
question
joe did you want to andy about cht
funding
um i was just answering council about it
all right in the chat um but i'll answer
it very quickly um
yes we do link in with uh uh house and
trust social investment board so we've
got a direct link in so my team leader
for street tour works closely with them
but we also work with partners which you
won't see
supporting them for bids that are going
in even uh and the group at the skate
park in in old trafford for instance
they're putting in a bit to to for some
money to do some redevelopment through
that particular route so yes we yes it's
the simple answer is yes we are aware
and we do work with them it's just
useful for some
voluntary groups that you may come
across and because obviously youth work
is at the forefront of the social
investment board's priorities so i just
wasn't sure how familiar you were with
what their priorities are
yeah yeah no no definitely and we have
we have got some joint work and
hopefully maybe maybe the next place
will will help a community group develop
it is in sale more
thank you
okay
thanks andy um
can we move on to um item seven um which
is the ofsted improvement um going to
hand over to phil it's a lengthy and
very comprehensive report could i ask
you to
sort of give us the highlights please
jill
you'll be pleased to know it's not me
that's going to talk to it denise
because you know i can talk um forever
and you're right we have provided a
comprehensive suite of information um
and some of the uh appended items i
would invite the the committee to to
look at
but um pamela wharton who's our director
for social care and early help is going
to pull out those key points and really
from our point of view what we wanted to
do was to have a little bit of an open
conversation um because i know um we
report regularly in terms of progress i
know
that um a number of um members of this
committee are also members of corporate
parenting board and so have a real keen
line of sight on
the things that we're doing so it was
really more to
be able to answer your questions your
queries
and have a little bit of a discussion
but i'll hand over to pamela at that
point thank you
good evening members um great to be here
with you and you you may recall that we
were last here on this item in october
and we just had a two-day offset
monitoring visit at that point uh the
28th and 29th of september and and
whilst we shared some um some overview
we couldn't share full details because
that hadn't been published it was
subsequently published on the 2nd of
november it is in your pack
and the areas of focus there
were was assessments and plans for
children across the continuum child in
need child protection and cared for
children with with also a look at our
missing response
um and and andy was for it for a quite a
period of time managing our missing
services as well and looking also at
management oversight and senior leaders
understanding of social work practice
so the the there is a really um clear
overview there that or
overall they found that children's
situations were improving as a result of
the interventions in place which was
really pleasing for us
but workforce instability and weaknesses
in first land management were impacting
on the quality of some of the
relationship and the decision making for
children
in terms of that leadership performance
management and corporate and political
commitment that was seen to be really
strong and that leaders have an accurate
understanding of quality of practice
so from from that visit and we've
reviewed our improvement plan
we have eight ambition streams and
continuing in the ambition plan but
three overarching priorities for all of
those
workforce stability
because without a stable workforce um we
we can't give families a consistent
offer
so that is our number one priority
leadership and management and the
quality of that direction and support to
our practitioners
and then that from flowing from that the
quality of practice is a third priority
so just in terms of of workforce and we
do continue to have
some instability our turnover rate is
higher than we would want at 17
and we have a number of children who've
had three or more social workers in a
12-month period
um and we we want to improve that
positively we have recruited 14 new
social workers
in the past six months the dfe uh
highlight report from january this year
highlights the the progress that we've
made in return in terms of our
recruitment and retention strategy and
our dfe
advisor claire burgess
um the language that she uses when she
talks to us is that we are doing all of
the right things
um and and so we are hopeful that we are
going to turn the curve around that
workforce stability
in respect of leadership and management
when offset visited us we were a couple
of weeks away from implementing our new
uh arrangements and our leadership team
and management team has changed as a
result of that restructure which the dfe
described as brave
um undertaking an improvement journey in
a pandemic whilst doing a whole service
redesign is very brave i am a little bit
like a parrot where i do say that in in
a lot of places
um but i this is my fourth improvement
journey i love an improvement journey
but there are particular challenges
about an improvement journey in a
pandemic um and the impact that that's
had on peace and momentum i don't think
can be underestimated
we have revised our supervision
frameworks we've established a
leadership forum our quality assurance
framework is really robust and is being
implemented by our managers and and just
to give you an an example of that in
terms of the number of audits completed
in quarter one
we completed 140
audits of practice
from first line managers and the heads
of service moderating
in in quarter two that was 111
and previously in previous years we
we've we've certainly been 100 under 50
audits per quarter so we've really
increased um that that one we have a
really rich understanding of what the
quality of our services to children and
families
in is and and of of the the over a
thousand cases open
um 90 of those have had a management
oversight
in quarter one and 88 in quarter two
so
continue to know that that this is an
area that we need to focus on in terms
of that line of sight to practice and
but we absolutely i think have our
managers hearts and minds
in in in that quality of practice is
really important for us um
we we have 30 of our audits judged to be
good
which is not where we want to be but is
is a is a an improvement on where we
were previously
the majority i'd say 50
are judged um in that requiring
improvement
and very small numbers and that
decreases month on month that are being
judged to be inadequate
um so we you know we are definitely
going in the right direction but but
we've got greater aspirations we we want
all of our children's work to be judged
to be good because we want to offer a
good and great service to all of our
children and young people
um we we had practice fortnight i don't
know whether some members were managed
to attend some of our sessions we had
750 practitioners and managers
and we expanded that to schools we had a
great session delivered by one of our
head teachers to our practitioners about
what it's like to run a school
absolutely fantastic you know that one
service approach across children's
services and and for the first time
we've done a practice fortnight to have
750 people attending those sessions and
i think that's nothing short of
phenomenal to be honest and we have
though aspirations that's not good
enough for us we want to continue to
progress
this next year we are planning to have
as our year of practice where we'll be
doing much more
around
learning and that continuous development
for all of our workforce we also have a
strengthening practice program that
we've commissioned which is a three-year
investment in our practitioners we've
started with the care and confidence
module and recognizing that this has
been a tough time for practitioners
on the front line um during during the
pandemic i'll try not to mention the
pandemic again i think i've probably
exceeded that now
but yeah really really excited to be
able to look after our practitioners in
this time ahead of doing a really
detailed program around assessment
planning um and helping parents we've
also got a program for managers and
leaders as well that we are
developing so i think in summary um a
phenomenal amount of work going on as
you can see from the ambition plan
update um which we're really proud of um
all of our workforce in in committing to
this journey with us we had a dfe review
uh last week we had some outcomes from
that shared with us at six monthly
review
and one of the most pleasing things that
they said
was that um whoever they speak to in
trafford be that senior leaders or
practitioners middle managers
it runs through us all like a stick of
rock that we are passionate about making
a difference to children and and what
the dfe who's seen
lots of places
says that is a very unusual for an
authority in improvement and we should
be really proud of that
long way to go
i i'm not resting on on
my laurels we know that variability
of practice is still an issue we're not
offering a consistent service um and and
that is our priority as we move forward
so i i will leave it there because i
know you'll have read the papers and
have i've have lots of things that you
want to explore with us i'm sure
councillor hans will want to come in as
well on some things as she's so expertly
uh leading us through all of this
alongside jill
thank you thank you pamela um
it it seems to be um
a regular
um i'm not going to call it a failing
because i know how hard we're trying
we're working to try and improve these
services the management oversight um
although we're getting better i'm just
wondering what steps we can put in place
to get it
to the level where
it is at we can be reassured and we know
that that's robust
can i come in on that one
i can't believe that in the things that
pamela said that she didn't mention two
of the critical things that we're doing
around that
one is that under pamela's leadership
we've established a leadership forum
that brings together all of our newly
created heads of service posts are
practice managers
and they have the opportunity to review
what's going well so where we've got
improvements but areas that we further
need to strengthen so it provides
not only a system for them networking
and building in that consistency of
response because it shouldn't matter
whether somebody goes to me pamela or
their frontline manager they should
expect the same kind of advice and
guidance
so that forum is absolutely critical in
terms of building that consistency
turning
shared expectations into real tangible
decisions on the ground
it's also helped our our leaders and
managers step up so you know just
creating a new post that happens to be
called a practice manager or a new post
that happens to be called a head of
service doesn't automatically bring
about the change that you would want so
it is a key
um od development forum
and managers have the opportunity to
share good things but also to be
challenged
and
that meets on a fortnightly basis and we
bring our audit findings in we bring
examples of work where it's good where
it isn't and that's really consolidating
and strengthening um
that group
the other thing that has been a critical
piece of work that has been rolled out
is we have revised our supervision
framework and it is a framework not a
policy because it just like pamela
talked about children running through
our practitioners and our managers like
as a stick of rock
supervision advice guidance support
being helpful is just so central to the
the manager's role
what was brilliant about that piece of
work was it was developed by
practitioners and managers for
practitioners and managers it wasn't
something that came out of pamela's head
my head
or our lead in terms of practice
improvement
it was something that people developed
as as a way forward to be helpful to
them
those two things coupled with that
formal um external program
are really um key
um
not just building blocks
because they're already in place but
they are the key platforms that will
enable us to
um strengthen and have greater
confidence in terms of everything that
our managers do because your point's
really well made you know if
we have to
um see our managers as the
the jam in the sandwich they are the
people that will absolutely make the
difference
um so we have developed a comprehensive
package
around them at every different level so
practicing practice
supporting and helping them
to develop their leadership and
management skills
developing their
ability to use the data really
effectively so as it's not something
that we say i've spotted this so they
can really live and breathe that
and through the redesign one of the
things that we have done is we've
changed the spans of control
and by that i mean that we have
dedicated heads of service with
dedicated practice managers that all fit
together so we're making their job
doable
we're giving them responsibility for
dedicated service areas and that was one
of the things that
people were really clear about they
wanted not to have disparate services
but they wanted it to make sense and our
children and families were saying some
of the ways that you organize yourself
doesn't make sense i don't know who
would go to for help on this or that so
we've changed all of that
and actually
not just supporting people but giving
them manageable jobs
and not setting them up to fail through
how we've organized our services i think
is a is a real key help
thank you jill that's very reassuring
and
i can see that councillor maitland has
their hand up um
do you have a question sue
yeah oh
not used to this setup at all um
is is this the um where uh john howarth
um involved her what she's putting
together
so john hall with us
she's an expert in the field in terms of
um child protection and safeguarding and
actually wrote some of the national
documents and guidance that we have to
work to in terms of assessments
and we've commissioned jan to come in
and work with our
child protection conference chairs and
our independent reviewing officers so
they're charged with the responsibility
of reviewing children's plans
and whether
we're effective in terms of progressing
those plans
and
john we've commissioned jan to do a
dedicated piece of work that will
involve as well talking to children and
families
about are our plans meaningful are they
written in the right way are they
helpful to them
we're delighted because jan can pick and
choose who she works with and she chose
to come to trafford because she thinks
that we are clear in terms of our vision
that we're really committed to making
improvements but that she can see that
we've got some good things in place
so yes she does come into this
arrangement as well and she will be
working with us across the whole service
but really focusing on those child
protection systems and care planning
systems
i i brought this up because going
through the ambition plan i obviously
there's lots of red and
lots of green which is great to see and
and amber on the rag rating and it's
just this is where the main focus of the
red
area seemed to be um and it looks like
you're waiting for jan to come
so
no janus actually started the work we've
made some internal changes but one of
the things that i think is is really
helpful to us is
that we've invited outside people and
learning from elsewhere
because it would be a sad day if we
thought we had all of the answers and
actually having an expert in the field
to help accelerate some of the changes
that we want to make but do that in a
very supportive way
so at the time that that was updated she
hadn't actually physically started on
the plot um and the rag rating we've
applied was where um we might have
started something but not got quite to
where we want it to be but that work has
now started
could i ask the cost of
jan's input
in terms of the cost of it
i would need to check the exact figure
and some of that is because we have
scoped and included time with parents
for example
um
but one of one of the beauties of using
people that are academics is they're
much cheaper than um
consultants because they have a vested
interest in it
and that's not to belittle her skills in
any way shape or form um so it's it it
is um
i think it's good value for money but i
can come back to you with the exact
figure thank you
and could i just ask um about the 4p
approach
links to some of the earlier
conversation and that focus on
prevention
really so it is about
prevention it's about
if
if prevention isn't being effective how
we protect the measures that we want to
do so it's very much focused in that
that space of exploitation and um youth
justice and it's something that has been
developed in in other boroughs in other
places and it's something that the
police really relate to because like i
say you think about preventing because
that's got to be the best way in in the
first instance you think about
protection and
the the final pay i can't remember what
the third one is but the final
prosecution yeah
yeah
i i just noticed though that you'd said
on the report it's limited progress
and one of the reasons why it's limited
progress is that actually um
it needs to be a system change it can't
just be something that we say we work in
this way it's got to be engaging with
partners and we've got to go on that
journey together so some of the things
that we have done
have been
development sessions scoping sessions
with the with the police in particular
and our safeguarding
our
complex safeguarding team and when
pamela talks about some of the impact of
pandemic
not being able to come together in those
spaces is is one of the challenges
i'm sorry i'm there jill i'm sure it'll
be recorded somewhere
my my my internet went up the wall then
i didn't know whether it was you or me
i mean if it if it's something in terms
of that particular approach and that way
of working then that is something that
we'd be happy to bring back to a future
committee meeting
thank you oh could i just ask one more
thing
um shine what does that stand for
shine is our complex safeguarding team
and they
work in a particular methodology calling
achieving change together we have
increased the number of workers in in
that team
and again like we talked about earlier
with andy's service about building those
intensive relationships with some of our
most vulnerable young people
the workers in that service don't hold
full case responsibility so there will
be a social worker in another team
and that almost frees them up very much
like andy's service to
um work much more creatively work much
more intensively but they are a
co-located team with the police and they
also have
a trusted relationship psychologist
that's funded by our health partners
we've recently recruited
a nurse into that service
and we are about to
commission
a parenting support worker because if
you're a parent
of somebody that's potentially at risk
of exploitation or being exploited you
might be doing everything possible to
keep
your your child your young person safe
but it's a challenging space to be in so
actually having some independent
parenting support is a critical part of
the model
thanks jill
thanks jill and thanks sue for the
questions and i think
safeguarding and child exploitation is
something that perhaps we'd like to look
into in in
um scrutiny in the future cath did you
want to comment at all yeah please um
denise thank you and so
i think and i will be brief but i just
wanted to reflect really a little bit on
um some of the things that i've been
really lucky to um to kind of be
involved in um and i've kind of
experienced um some of the child's
journey
work and which was really really
powerful um and i've had um kind of some
of the training around the child impact
chronologies and i did attend some of
the the practice fortnight sessions and
i've met with the um
practice improvement and
that's not what they're called a partner
and and all of those things have been
really really powerful and what struck
me about them is that they are different
ways of working and they're they're a
different way of practicing for social
workers um
and
and because they are really different i
think it
you can see how because i know members
have asked questions in the past around
you know that pace of change around the
quality of practice and why are we not
seeing that picking up in a much in a
much quicker way and but when you've
kind of
seen the amount of um
support and training that that's going
in
what struck me about it was that
when you've still got um a little bit of
instability like we've had in the in the
workforce and you've got kind of a
little bit of turnover of staff when
you're trying to embed that change and
get people um used to being able to
practice in those areas um and also
you're trying to do that whilst you're
in um
going through the pandemic and all of
the things and that that's kind of
disrupted you can see how that that will
have been a little bit more difficult to
embed
um but what i think has been really
clear so there's been so much work
that's been going on for such a long
time and
and all those building blocks have been
being put really carefully in in place
and and the restructure for me feels
like it's been the final part of that
jigsaw in a way and because i
jill says oh no no no it wasn't brave it
was something that was just entirely
necessary but i do think it was really
brave to do a restructure um on that
scale you know during these really
tricky times in an improvement journey
when we've still got um the impact of
the pandemic but it was really necessary
um and we are through the other side and
we're starting really now to see
um what an incredible impact that is
having actually and um
the the fact that
the managers
have got that
that
oversight of their bit of work um in a
much clearer way i think does give them
that line of sight on onto the work um
that that you know that they need to
have really in a way that they possibly
didn't have quite as as much off before
but also the
and i'm you know i'm really hopeful that
this is going to continue but we have
recruited people to to permanent roles
um now and
that
kind of instabilities is definitely
starting to settle down and as a result
of all that i think all that work that's
gone on beforehand is ongoing
now has that real opportunity to embed
and we're starting to see that real
difference and it feels like those
building blocks are really there and
really optimistic that actually we'll
start to see that coming through now
directly into the practice and into the
grip and that the managers have on that
and the supervision framework will help
i think managers have got a
much better idea of what good looks like
than they had and people talking to me
you know you can really hear that and
so i am really hopeful um and i think
you know the team have done such an
amazing job and bringing everybody
through that and bringing people through
not only in one piece but i think really
in such a um you know such a positive
and strong
way so those would be my comments but
that's not to say and jill and i will be
ready to just jump in immediately now
and but to say that isn't to say that we
don't recognize that there's still you
know a lot to do and it's important that
you know we now start to see those
changes
thanks kath and we i think we have
actually got the recruitment and
retention of social workers and foster
carers on the agenda for the next
meeting so uh be interesting to see um
there
i'm just very conscious of the time oh
sorry counselor blackburn have you got a
question yes just quickly um i think in
a recent meeting jill mentioned you know
about the turnover and stuff
has that turnover affected the data to
do with the audits of practice
and
with the new staff becoming embedded
well
when do you sort of expect that you know
the um the sort of uh requires
improvement to go in into the good
section thank you
that's almost like the million dollar
question isn't it the the when um and i
guess as pamela said we are seeing
movements and we are seeing improvements
we're seeing more
audits as being rated as good
one of the things that we've started to
see as well in terms of some of the
changes that that we've made is an
increase in the number of compliments to
the service we often talk about the
complaints that we get
and pamela shared a lovely compliment
with me today about one of our new
practitioners that's newly recruited so
we recruited a domestic violence
specialist to work in our front door
she took up post
um
middle of last month i think it was that
she actually took up post
and we had some feedback from another
agency that was also working with family
and it simply said you have
turned my life around
you have
and it was that strong the language
so
measuring some of the compliments as
well as the the improvements through the
audit
but as people come in new everybody has
a
bespoke induction package and for our
managers that includes our audit our
quality assurance activity
they have a one-to-one coaching session
because you're right
for it to be meaningful it's got to loop
back to practice
um
i am confident that when we get
re-inspected
that
the cha that hofstede will absolutely
validate the changes that we've made um
already through the monitoring process
as well as saying there's more to do
they are saying we can see
areas of real improvement
and that will ultimately be the the when
won't it when external validation um
confirms that the changes have had
impacts for our children and young
people
i guess the other thing that was really
pleasing in the dfe review is
not just that our practitioners and
managers are talking about children and
young people and wanting to make a
difference with them
but they've stopped thinking about um
offstat because if we're doing the right
things for children if we're working
in a helpful way in a restorative way in
a relational way with our children and
families and we're getting it right
often takes care of itself
and i know that sounds really simple
but that i genuinely believe that if
we're doing the right things then
whatever inspection it is we'll
benchmark that so the important driver
for us is doing the right things to be
helpful for our children and families
great
thanks jill um and
thank you um
for your questions um thank you to
everybody that's been here this evening
um i'm not acquir aware of any um urgent
business
so
um if everybody's happy um
i'm going to close the meeting um next
meeting is the 15th of march which will
be the last one for
this municipal year it seems to have
gone very very quickly um
so i would like to wish everybody um
a safe journey to wherever you're going
on to
and
thank you again